Game of Thrones Season 8 episode 5 is
the bells
it starts with Varys writing letters
about John's Targaryen identity he's
spreading the word and getting support
for John to be king
Varys speaks with Martha one of his
spies or little birds apparently she and
Varys are trying to poison Daenerys so
Varys is betraying Daenerys and now
supports John Varys tells John that he
would be a good king which might not be
true
John is good at leading and fighting but
he has no experience with southern
politics with council meetings and plots
and intrigue john is a lot like his
uncle Ned an honourable honest Northman
and Ned only lasted a season in the
capital before he was outplayed and
killed John only lasted as commander of
the Nights Watch for a season before he
was killed
meanwhile Daenerys has been learning to
rule for eight seasons so why is Varys
so sure that John would be a better
ruler Varys says every time a Targaryen
is born the gods toss a coin and the
world holds its breath it's a common
saying because while some Targaryen
Kings have been wise and good others
have been violent and cruel like
Daenerys his father the Mad King Varys
is worried that Dany might snap and burn
King's Landing as it turns out he's
totally right but up until now Danny's
been very reasonable in a conquest of
Westeros she tried all of Tyrion stupid
plans to end the war peacefully and she
came north to save the world from White
Walkers when she could have just taken
the throne
she's doing all the right things so why
is Varys so certain she's nuts that he
wants to poison her Faris had once
supported Viserys Targaryen
but Daenerys is too crazy for him in the
books Varys has totally different
motivations that make a lot more sense
go watch that video but in the show he
supports Jon over Daenerys John says
he's loyal to Dany and that she's his
queen but Varys says men decide where
power resides and this refers to Varys
as riddle in season two the idea is that
kings and priests and money only have
power if people believe they have
John says power in Daenerys but he could
choose to see power in himself tyrion
finds out about varus's betrayal and
tells Daenerys and Daenerys is
unsurprised she's numb to anymore loss
she had begged John not to reveal his
identity but he told Sansa and Sansa
told Tyrion - Varys who used it to
betray Daenerys all of her allies have
failed her miss and I Rhaegar and Jorah
dead Danny feels that there is no one
she can trust like everyone's against
her no matter what she does Daenerys
executes Varys and he calmly accepts his
fate he was willing to risk his life for
the sake of the realm tyrion tells Varys
that it was him who snitched on him to
Danny
Tyrion feels guilty for betraying one of
his only friends
they say farewell and Dani burns Varys
alive just as she promised she would
Daenerys and grey worm grieve for Masson
die grey worm throws her old slave
collar into fire Masson dies last word
was drew chorus which means Dragon Fire
so Danny and grey worm will express
their grief in fiery violence
Daenerys confronts John for telling
Sansa about his identity even though she
begged him not to can Daenerys rely on
her lover John she kisses him but he
pulls away he was disturbed to see her
burn Varys so John's not too keen on
macking his art with even John rejecting
her Danny feels that no one in Westeros
loves her she decides to use fear to
take power Danny decides to attack
King's Landing Tyrion warns her that
that would kill thousands of innocents
but Danny says that's worth it if they
can remove Cersei and that's not an
unusual attitude in Westeros when the
lords make war common folk die that's
how it is like 20 years ago the
Lannisters killed many innocent people
in King's Landing removing the Mad King
but Tyrion hopes for Daenerys to take
the capital peacefully he says if the
city bells ring that means they've
surrendered so the attack can stop
Dany agrees but she's clearly cane for
fire and
ayuh and the hound passed through the
wall camp ayah says she's going to kill
Cersei and if she mentioned that earlier
Daenerys could have held off the attack
that had been no need for battle and no
dead civilians if ayah stock in and
killed Cersei but I is too edgy and cool
to share her plans with Jon Tyrion frees
Jaime he was captured by Daenerys trying
to get to Cersei Tyrion once Jaime to
convince Cersei to surrender so that the
people of King's Landing won't die it's
funny that Tyrion is trying so hard to
save these people when in season four he
said he wanted to kill the people of
King's Landing in the books Tyrion still
in this dark vengeful place but in the
shoten Eris has changed Tyrians
worldview inspired him to believe in a
better world
Jaime doesn't believe in a better world
he says he never cared about the people
of King's Landing which is weird because
Jaime once killed his King to save the
people of King's Landing
to stop the Mad King from burning the
city maybe this is just Jaime using his
Kingslayer persona again he's acting
cruel and careless to hide how
conflicted he really is over the last
eight seasons Jaime's grown beyond that
Kingslayer persona he left Cersei and
risked his life to fight for the living
with Brienne but now he's suddenly
regressing back to the selfish person he
used to be
Tyrion gets Davos to put a boat outside
the red cape so that Jaime and Cersei
can escape Jaime once saved Tyrians life
so now Tyrion tries to save his the
brothers have a heartfelt final farewell
in the capital Cersei prepares to defend
her throne she brings common people up
around the red cape thinking the
Daenerys won't want to kill innocent
people the golden company and Euron's
fleet are defending the city until
Daenerys attacks she flies down from
above with the Sun behind her and wipes
out the entire i inflate even though the
fleet has dozens of scorpion ballistas
last episode urine hit the dragon
Rhaegar with three scorpion bolts
Daenerys and Dragon couldn't handle just
11 of Euron ships
time Euron has over a hundred ships and
Daenerys destroys them all
she also burns the dozens of scorpions
on the city walls as if it's nothing
not a single scorpion vault hits the
scorpions were such a huge threat last
episode but now they're a non-issue the
same thing happens with the golden
company so she went to a lot of trouble
to hire these guys borrowing money from
the iron bank having Euron ship of them
across the sea Circe says that the most
powerful army in Essos but an heiress
wipes them out before they can do
anything their soldiers attack and
quickly overwhelm the Lannisters so the
show leads us to believe that we're
gonna get a big epic battle between the
good guys and bad guys but the show
subverts that by having Daenerys easily
stomp Circe's army it leads us to
question whether Dany and John really
are the good guys a lot of these shots
echo the Battle of the bastards except
now John is in the role of the Bolton's
and it gets worse from here the
Lannisters surrender and the city bells
ring so Daenerys achieves the impossible
she takes the capital with very few
deaths she can just go to the red cape
arrest Cersei and end the war Danny can
take the Iron Throne as a peaceful queen
a liberator and protector of the people
this is what Daenerys always wanted but
when it happens she doesn't feel happy
she only feels grief and anger she's
lost Masson died and Rhaegar and Jorah
everyone's turned against her despite
all her sacrifices she feels alone and
overwhelmed and she snaps she burns the
city and the innocent people in it she
spends the rest of the episode
systematically destroying King's Landing
by the end most of the city is on fire
and there are a million people in there
so Daenerys kills hundreds of thousands
of innocent men women and children not
for any strategic reason but because
she's angry and sure maybe she's
inspiring fear to force people to follow
her but it's clear from the scene and
from interviews with actors and show
runners that this isn't a political
calculation
this is an emotional outburst that leads
to the deaths of hundreds of thousands
of innocent people this is more death
and destruction than anyone has ever
caused in Game of Thrones Tywin and
Cersei and Ramsay never killed hundreds
of thousands of civilians only the White
Walkers are that bad
so Daenerys is arguably as evil as the
night King he brought an apocalypse of
ice now she brings an apocalypse of fire
which nicely sums up the Robert Frost
poem that inspired this series the world
could end in ice or fire neither would
suffice so there is meaning here it's
about how human conflict is just as
destructive as magic White Walkers like
the humans defeated the zombies but it
turns out the humans with a real
monsters all along it's kind of a cliche
but author George Martin always said
that Thrones isn't about good guys and
bad guys it's about the human heart in
conflict with itself
human nature is what destroys King's
Landing
so this disaster does fit with the
themes of the series but how does it fit
with Daenerys as character is she really
this evil Daenerys has always struggled
to balance violence and vengeance
against peace and compromise she wants
to be a fair ruler but sometimes she
gets angry and does violence that isn't
politically smart or just like in season
4 she crucified a hundred masters in
season five she fed masters to her
dragons even though she said some might
be innocent and in season seven she
burned the Tally's some of these might
be justifiable but they were all
killings motivated by anger a Targaryen
urge for fire and blood and Danny's
often wanted to go further to let her
dragons loose and to burn all her
enemies in season two she threatens calf
saying she'll burn cities to the ground
in season four she decides to kill every
master in yunkai and in season six to
kill the Mira neighs to return their
cities to the dirt both these times to
nurses advisors convinced her not to
wipe out cities Jorah and Tyrion check
worst impulses so in season eight when
jour is dead and Danny's lost faith in
Tyrion there's no one to hold her back
she expresses her grief and rage in fire
and blood when Aegon the conquerer
sister died Aegon burned every console
and Cape in dawn and the civilian deaths
were uncountable this is what tag Aryans
do this is what Dragons represent
destruction fire and fury but why would
Daenerys attack civilians part of what
defines her as a character is her
sympathy for the common people for the
weak and innocent because as a child
Daenerys herself was treated as a slave
abused by her brother sold to Drogo used
and raped so as soon as she starts
getting power she uses it to protect the
vulnerable she saves Lazar reign women
she protects her calluses she spends
three seasons liberating slaves
Daenerys once locked away her dragons to
prevent them from hurting kids so angry
or not murdering hundreds of thousands
of innocents goes against one of the
foundations of Daenerys as character if
this happens in the books we might see a
more gradual progression into this
violence so we can better understand why
she does it
well the situation could be different
like maybe Danny will only kill the
people at the red cape who are actually
in the way of the throne or she could
accidentally burn the city by setting
off this wildfire the wild fires
leftover from when the Mad King tried to
burn the city so Daenerys unknowingly
ignites her father's legacy whatever her
reasons Daenerys has become what she
came to destroy she's queen of the ashes
a bringer of death a tyrant grey worm
sparks violence on the ground attacking
the Lannisters who'd surrendered to
avenge the death of missandei and the
Starks soldiers join in they have reason
to hate the Lannisters Lannister's
killed their beloved Ned and their King
Robb and gave the north to the brutal
Bolton's thousands of North men died in
wars against the Lannisters so now they
get revenge it's a bit like in the books
when north men march against the
Bolton's and
Northmen called big bucket wool says let
me bathe in Boulton blood before I die
there's a tradition in the north for
older Northman to get themselves killed
before winter so their families have one
less mouth to feed many of the Northmen
who came south with John might not have
planned to return so it's no surprise
that this becomes a bloodbath
John watches in horror as his men
slaughter and rape civilians in season 3
Jorah says there's a beast in every man
and it stirs when you put a sword in his
hand we like to think of the Northman as
good guys but the story shows how even
people with good intentions can become
monsters in war ire and the Hound
reached the Cape and the Hound tells her
to turn back io wants to kill Cersei and
finish her death list but the Hound
tells her not to become like him
the hounds been obsessed with revenge
all his life ever since his brother the
mountain burned his face that anger and
bitterness is why the Hound is so lonely
cynical and unhappy if I akil's Cersei
it'll only take her deeper into violence
and alienation the Hound says if she
stays here she'll die she could die
literally from the castle collapsing but
she could also die metaphorically if her
humanity is consumed by violence and
hate like how Mira said that brand died
so I achoo zzz's life and turns back
from the precipice she thanks the Hound
and calls him Sandor his real name it's
a moment of human connection between
ayah and Sandor Clegane
so I aterna the Hound thinks it's too
late for him he goes and finds his
brother these two have wanted to kill
each other for years
and here at the end of the world seems
as good a time as any
Qyburn orders the mountain to stay but
he disobeys and kills his creator
remember the mountain had been all but
dead when Qyburn raised him as a zombie
man with some mix of science and
necromancy Qyburn is like dr.
Frankenstein and the mountain is his
monster
so it's neatly poetic for Qyburn to be
killed by his creation
we see the mountains phases old rotted
now no matter what the hound does to him
he won't die cuz Gregor is already dead
the brother who burned Sandor is long
gone all that's left is a walking corpse
this shows the pointlessness and
emptiness of revenge the Hound will
never find happiness by killing a dead
man
but the Hound feels this can only end
with death so he takes the mountain down
with him pushing him through a wall into
the fires below fire is what started
their beef when Gregor burned Sandor and
fire is the only thing that could kill
the undead mountain so the brothers burn
together Jamie tries to reach Cersei by
a passage to the red cape but he's
stopped by urine urine survived Danny's
attack on his flate and he rises from
the sea the Ironborn have a ritual of
drowning themselves than being revived
because what is dead may never die but
rises again harder and stronger Iran
starts a fight with Jaime
they've been rivals for Circe's love
since last season Jaime kills Euron but
Jamie's badly wounded
so urines happy that he's the man who
killed Jaime Lannister Euron in the show
is a simple man with simple goals he
wanted to be king to [ __ ] the Queen and
to kill Jaime and with that done he dies
content Jaime gets to Cersei and the
twins embrace as the world falls down
around them they try to escape but their
passage is blocked by rubble Cersei had
stayed defiant while Daenerys burned her
city but now she breaks down and cries
for the life of her baby and herself
because deep down Cersei is only human
Jaime tells her that she and him are the
only things that matter in the world
just as they said in season 1 and then
the roof collapses and they die this is
a poetic end for Cersei
she is crushed beneath the red cape a
symbol of the power that she wanted so
badly that it destroyed her
Cersei could have saved herself at any
time in the last couple seasons but
Cersei couldn't let go of power and so
it collapsed upon her
Sosa's pregnancy plotline went nowhere
all that stuff about whether Jamie or
Iran was the father and whether the baby
would make says he cooperate maybe the
showrunners thought that pregnancy would
humanize Cersei as their motherhood is
the only relatable aspect of Circe's
deep complex character in the last two
seasons
Cersei did very little but get pregnant
drink wine and die Jaime's death makes
him a failure he tried to redeem himself
to be a better man with Brienne but he
just couldn't escape Cersei Jaime
changes so much throughout his arc but
he ends up dying in the same place he
began maybe this is realistic
some people don't change the showrunners
say that Jaime's love for Cersei is like
an addiction and sometimes addicts
relapse and overdose but you've got to
ask what's the point of the last eight
seasons of Jaime's arc if he abandons
all his growth to die with Cersei Jaime
dies with his hand on Circe's neck which
evokes the valonqar prophecy from the
books which hints that Cersei will be
strangled to death by Jaime it may be
that in the books Jaime will kill Cersei
before he dies that way Jaime could
overcome his darker half before his
death in season five Jaime says he wants
to die in the arms of the woman he loves
some fans hoped that would be Brienne
but it turns out that was Cersei the
prophecy of Maggy the Frog said that
Cersei would be cast down by someone
younger and more beautiful
Cersei thought that meant Margaery but
it turns out that's Daenerys bringing
the Cape down on to Cersei also Daenerys
could fit the Dothraki prophecy of the
stallion who mounts the world and
tramples nations into dust
so season age does fulfill some of the
series prophecies son foreshadowing
while the city burns IOC's the
devastation on the ground she trained
for seasons to be a servant of death but
now she sees how horrible death can be
with hundreds of innocents suffering and
screaming and grieving a common woman
help sire a moment of hope in the
darkness so IO tries to say
the woman and other civilians they end
up dying anyway but the point is that
ayah is trying to help people for once
instead of just killing after the
devastation I arises from the ashes and
cries over the bodies of the people she
tried to save the visuals of Oh Pompeii
and 9/11 and the bombing of Dresden ash
rains down like nuclear winter author
George Martin says his dragons are like
nuclear weapons IOC's a horse
the only other living creature among the
death of the horse is white with red
blood just like a weirwood is white with
a red SAP so this could connect to the
old gods some fans think that this horse
was sent by bran with his walking powers
or it could connect to the Book of
Revelations in the Bible where a pale
horse means death but I astrak-- the
horse we hear its breathing and see its
face aya rides it out of the ruins away
from the death and destruction aya and
her horse represent life but overall
this is a very dark episode hundreds of
thousands are killed by the woman we
thought was a hero
Jaime fails to become a better man and
dies with his hateful sister all of
John's heroism and varus's scheming and
Tyrians supposed intelligence did
nothing to prevent this disaster his
Game of Thrones really this bleak and
nihilistic Thrones author George Martin
says his worldview is anything but
nihilistic Thrones is full of death and
darkness but the darkness is there to
better show the light of human struggles
against darkness men's lives have
meaning not their deaths
and yet this episode has little but
death there's a sense of inevitability
Varys talks about Targaryen madness as
though Daenerys was destined to repeat
her father's sins Jamie just accepts
that he could never be better than the
hateful man he was The Hound basically
commits suicide by mountain it's as
though all these characters hopes and
growth were for nothing the dream of a
better world is ash so what was the
point of this story if ur just
with failure and death the Thrones books
always have some sense of meaning
against the darkness their ending will
be bittersweet not just better if
Thrones is to be true to its source
material and is to rise above empty
nihilism it needs to show some hope in
the series finale next week there are
many great game of Thrones YouTube
channels and a bunch of them just wrote
a book together about how Thrones became
so popular and so meaningful to so many
people it's called the Thrones affect
how HBO's Game of Thrones conquered pop
culture it's written and read by all of
these Thrones channels including history
of Westeros got Academy grey area and
more and you can get it on audiobook for
free today by signing up for a trial
with audible members get a book each
month and if you cancel you keep the
books so go and support some of the best
voices on Thrones online and hear new
perspectives on the story sign up at
audible.com slash ASX thanks for
watching the final Q&A livestream is on
10:30 eastern time Sunday night thanks
to the patrons including Sam London of
how simply first of his name lord of
Union Square and protector of the realm
thanks to Peter Meehan Jerry Oshkosh
Emily McNally bloody tyrant Nikko's
Moria Tarkas Trace Mikkel Joel so c-max
bqo and Golden Age Cheers